all right and we are live the last word
lord cognito ibontis thai guy travis
fresh on that thursday evening season of
the haunted campfire ivantas how you
doing sir uh doing good waiting even
more for tomorrow but we'll get to that
um
yeah it's been it's been a week it was
what was it fred monday night i think
technically when all the chaos basically
began and i think it was japanese
playstation that leaked the trailer and
then they just hit the premiere button
on their youtube and everybody went
running it did work because i got to do
you know videos and looking at stuff
like before sleep what i wanted to then
get up and play so i didn't have to like
try and cram
analyzing everything in three hours so i
was okay with that um but other than
that pretty much just you know 100
percent season of the haunted what about
you
um well every season is season of the
haunted for me
uh because i'm so haunted by
my past actions and uh
[Laughter]
sometimes it's more funny when it
doesn't come together or maybe that was
my whole point i'm going to say it was
intentional um so yeah uh mcclunkey
everyone welcome to our show
welcome to the
the last word with ty guy travis and his
co-hosts ebontist
[Laughter]
because i've seen star wars stuff on my
feed like all day are you like yeah man
a bunch of star wars stuff going on
i have a bunch of content coming out in
the next couple days and weeks had a
preview go live today i think i have
another one going live tomorrow or
monday or something and
yeah man my content machine out here
yeah
good time how about you eat how you
doing what's life like
yeah what's up e yes how are you doing
your state which i will simply just
refer to it as your statement oh uh this
week how's what's life how are things i
am lucky enough to be at least
geographically far away from that but
nice um
yeah not a fan of my state mostly um
obviously there are some
bright moments where you hear about in
the news but most of it has been very
very tragic and awful
when last week we're talking about
a terrible tragedy that happened up
north in cog state and then now we're
down here talking about a tragedy of
more
which doesn't matter on the number
they're all awful but another one and
this was now kids in a classroom and
just
the more you're getting out of the news
it's terrible and
heartbreaking yeah like i mean 19 kids
and the two adults as well like ev 21
people lost their lives in 45 minutes
and it's terrible but it's just like
it's that many
kids i mean how many kids went to school
that day and now the parents are not
having that kid come home i cannot
honestly fathom
so no not great and it's just one of
those things where
the i mean just some of the rhetoric
that's going on some of the stuff you've
seen for senators on the house floor and
things like that and i hate to cover
this first but the idea is like
when is ever going to be the time to
take action people say don't make it
political and all these other things
it's just like something does crazy to
me
yeah it's like it's
that the whole thing is it is that way
it has become a political thing because
of
years and years and years of what's been
kind of pushed and for me it's just
terrible sitting here it's like i am
very sheltered in my home not having to
deal with any of this not in any of
these places and very lucky but the more
you see this and the more it's just
constant and the fact that it just seems
to be getting worse year after year
it's been
the past like four or five years it's
been just almost exponential at some
point something's got to change and it's
just sad if it doesn't happen sooner
than later and unfortunately
just the way the government is set up i
even saw somebody just you know give the
president a hard time the way the
parties are set up right now the ways
the synod is set up not a lot of people
can do anything and it's really terrible
yeah yeah
you know
you know the way i've been thinking
about it
and i hate to make i hate to make this
about like
us gamers but the way i think about it
as gamers is like it's like tread
carefully
whatever whatever you think about
gun rights which
you know i'm i'm a guy who thinks some
people probably can have guns and we
could be okay
but uh
i think as gamers we can all agree
you got to balance your sandbox a little
bit
and i think i think we can agree maybe
the ar-15 deserves a nerf you know what
i mean like yo
this is a gaming show right let's bring
it back to gaming if
think of the air 15 like telesto right
it's doing some stuff it probably wasn't
designed to do the sandbox is all out of
whack it's just common sense right you
gotta you gotta nerf you gotta nerf uh
some stuff that's that's my that one
that one needs that one needs vaulted
yeah it needs to be vaulted maybe you
know so
um yeah it's it's a weird situation but
yeah
i mean
it's it's awful it's awful and at the
end of the day it's just like
i'm just so for where i'm from sadly
i've become so desensitized because it
just continues to happen so it's just
like
you know i don't know what it's going to
take and i don't want to go left with
you know this whole situation but yeah
you know when i the news broke and i saw
some accounts and
just gut-wrenching stuff heartbreaking
stuff heartbreaking you know parents and
their children and and losing them in
that manner and and the actions that was
taken and not taken so
this we got a long way to go on this
sandbox
you know i'm saying that we got a long
way to go they they gonna have to sunset
some things
like there needs to be some sun setting
some vaulting yep just yeah it needs to
happen
in destiny context correct yep yep like
travis said
so that's a way to phrase it yeah hope
you guys pick up what we're putting down
cool if you don't agree everybody's
allowed to have you know different
opinions but
yeah at this point um yeah it's like if
you guys saw steve kerr literally at the
press conference of the nba playoff game
just nothing about basketball just lost
like
just one just said it's like what is it
going to take when is it going to be
enough all of those things it's all of
that type of stuff is
at and at this point nothing seems like
it can get
nothing can get done right now there's a
couple bills that are literally sitting
i've learned this from all the news that
came out that are just sitting in the
senate and won't get voted on
and we want to know why it's like you
can go into it but it's just all of
those nothing seems to have been done
and it's just really sad to see the
stagnant state of things and it just
keeps happening
so hopefully we don't get one soon but
the way the statistics of the numbers
are going because man i hope not
yeah
what's the definition of insanity
repeating the same things expecting
different results yep
yeah it's like how long is it going to
take so
yeah i was like there's different
debates and numbers and facts you can go
into all the news and do your own
research that's one of the biggest
things like whichever way you lean do
research before you're just like hey do
this or that or the other try and do
your own research and come to a decision
that has some facts behind it not just
what you hear on one station or what you
hear on another because everything tends
to lean one direction try and gather
your own information and make a coherent
decision and have proper information
before you just say hey i was told this
one thing i'm going to believe that 100
that's it go out there do some research
figure out what you know the facts are
and then try and go from there
well that being said since apparently
we're gonna start every week with just a
terrible tragedy to cover hopefully not
um
yeah monday night stuff exploded now the
goal from what i gathered from twitter
was they were gonna drop the trailer a
few hours before launch
and i saw gary clay i think he is
marketing
i'd have to look him up on twitter he's
i've followed him forever
oh senior director of marketing can say
it was a bunchy okay yeah i wasn't far
off um he basically said a few hours is
as close as they can get before things
get spoiled and published by consoles
and platforms and other things because
it has to at that point they have to
update store pages and things like that
tend to happen so a few hours before is
what they were shooting for
we got
about
i don't know 18 hours before
i was literally upstairs watching dinner
hanging out with my wife and just
chilling i was like all right
everything's gonna happen tomorrow and i
look on twitter and just seems like
chaos is happening i was like
so i was like all right uh dinner's over
i will i gotta go work and then went
downstairs and took care of that stuff
streamed a whole bunch of people tuned
in for it so thank you guys
and
yeah so we got trailer website update it
all just showed up at the same time so
before we even get to our experience
playing it i just wanted to see what you
guys thought with
did you like the
marketing the attempt at waiting to a
few hours before even if it did break
early would you have liked to seen it
that close would you rather have had
solar 3.0 last week where do you guys
feel this marketing cycle
theoretically could have gone outside of
of course like you're dropping early
where do you think it could have gone
and should have gone now that you have
you know some more information
yeah i mean for me
it's funny because i'm indifferent still
because what i realize is this
it doesn't matter when they drop it i
just see people lose their minds and
it's just a testament to bungie's
marketing and and the way they do a
trailer and the way they showcase stuff
because
um
you know there's a part there's a part
of me that i was like all right what are
they gonna do there's the secrecy behind
it
and then
there's another part of me and it's just
like it really doesn't matter because
they're just so good so someone on
twitter sent you shout out to my boy
slow mo backslide who was kind of a a
destiny hater and he had like i thought
it was like the tweet
he was kind of like
you know i need to be a part of budgie's
you know marketing team because he said
i could see destiny fans be as angry as
they were about the state of the game
but when that trailer drops all is
forgiven and budgie knows how to get us
back and it it's just like cl it's like
psychological clockwork i see leviathan
i get the feels i see health we'll get
into all that stuff but to your question
um i mean it's better it doesn't it
doesn't matter when they drop a trail
because when they drop it it's on
regardless but trav where you at do you
think um do they have that effect for
you or would you prefer to show it early
i think the reason they didn't show it
early is because they thought that the
um
that that they thought there might be a
little bit of a backlash personally we
talked about this last week about how
when you don't show a trailer it's
either because you're super confident or
because you're you don't want to show
what you've got and i we i think we had
all speculated that based on bungie's
reaction that they were super hyped for
the season and that it was going to be a
much bigger season than we thought and
now that i've played it i'm starting to
wonder if maybe it was the other
so that's where i'm at i'm starting to
wonder if maybe they're going to get it
because
it's
a reused area it's a lot of kind of you
know twiddling their thumbs they brought
back the the the um
what do you call it no the the ghosts
the phantoms the the nightmares
the nightmares from the moon which like
a lot of people did not like in shadow
keep um so i was sort of wondering if if
maybe it was a strategic decision of
like hey look let's not
get them too hyped let's just sort of
like keep it and then
that way when they when they get to play
it they'll be like hey this is great
because i didn't have that hype build up
but i wonder if them not showing
anything had the opposite effect and
maybe they didn't intend that because
them not showing anything may destiny
stands be like oh well then this is
going to be way bigger than anybody
expects and then when it came out it was
sort of the opposite so i'm wondering if
them not showing anything meant that
people's imaginations sort of got ahead
of them and we we got our hopes really
really built up for a season that so far
just my experiences is kind of um
shallow just from what i've played so
far so anyway that's that's where i'm at
but uh we'll get into the actual stuff
but my reaction when i saw the marketing
was
huh
okay we'll see and then i played it like
a couple hours later and i was like
maybe maybe yeah maybe i get why they
weren't they weren't trying to hype this
up too much so
uh yeah i mean i
enjoyed the trailer i was digging in and
looking through it um
i'm at the point to where
seeing everything we got
it'd be a point where you could do
bait like tiny teases
you could
you know you could like have a picture
of like an arc and a solar thing and
then just slowly like you know like pan
it like different ways in different like
little tweets and stuff you could show
little clips of like you know little
pieces here and there something that
looks like maybe the glycon which we'll
get to in a minute but would carry over
a little bit more you'd be like oh
they're going
maybe i think they could have done a
little bit
without giving basically anything away
but i think they could have given us
just a little more of a tease
uh you
little i said a little tease like
there's no but i mean but again to build
like a little bit you know five second
little teaser here like 10 second little
baby thing here like little stuff to
like build the anticipation even more we
were all waiting but we had nothing then
if you built it a little more than they
could have but i mean
travis said too it's like they may have
known what they have and honestly it's
like seeing what the narrative team did
yeah so far i will say the narrative
team is 100 happy to be hyped and i see
why from playing the first mission from
seeing what kind of happened so far i
totally get what they're doing and i'm
kind of excited to see where it goes
because so far just in the first week
the acting and stuff so far is crushing
it
that's what i've thoroughly enjoyed real
quick before i forget necromancer zeal
uh the cabal and cattle are back cabal
in the helm loving solar 3.0 great
season so far thank you for the 10 super
chat appreciate that
um but yeah that was
i think they
i think it's a balance of what they have
again now we know arc 3.0 is coming so
there's no like keeping that a secret
when it comes to season 18. so that's
gonna be
maybe shown off a little bit more maybe
you could be like hey like say solar 3.0
okay it's like keeping that you know
close to the vest or not i don't think
that could have made or break either way
but now say when you get to season 18
learn from this one and say okay here's
one fragment
think about what you could do with this
one type thing like here's one or two
t's one fragment t's one aspect and do
like a little bit don't give show the
whole deck of cards but show a little
here and there it like in the lead up
and be like hey we're not gonna show you
all of our 3.0 because you all know it's
coming but here's a couple things to
like you know get your brain right yeah
they used to do stuff like that before i
think they used to they used to be like
in a twab they'd give you like hey
here's a little sample of whatever i
remember
and you could like even just show a demo
of like one thing working in like a
little baby you know twitter video or
something but just a balance of
overall like
i'm okay with how how it went down i
appreciate it personally like for making
content that i didn't have to like try
and get up early try and cram it all in
like i had one video done that had
another one go up like the next morning
because i broke down the trailer and
then the website
and i was able to space it out so for me
at least the day helps
just you know covering it
and for anybody who wants to cover it a
little bit of like preview is beneficial
to that one three hours before is barely
enough time to like analyze it figure
out what's important to cover and then
actually make a video post the video and
then play
so
in that sense i would say thanks for the
leak early i'll take 18 you know 24
hours it doesn't have to be like three
weeks in advance i need to know that arc
3.0 are coming and we're going to the
dreaming city to fix the loop or
whatever for season 18. i don't want to
know all that stuff but like you know 24
hours before that's fine i'm good with
that that's cool like so that's kind of
my take on the marketing piece and
kind of takes
us into the next piece
when you guys logged in what did you
guys think of basically the first little
cinematic that something i wondered
about for a very long time about one of
our little social spaces it moved
we've got a spaceship now thoughts yeah
i was
look i know the joke it's a reused asset
i get it
no yeah that was cool i was cool i was
all right we we mobile command center
like no doubt like let's get it like let
i mean that that's how it should be
theoretically with all these threats
universal threats paracores or threats
you know what i'm saying like and now
with the alliances because let's be
honest you know i've always felt as much
as
they're doing these cool things with
alliance i always thought it's a bit
much to have
the alien race just running around
a bit that's just falling off
like yeah you're like all right fine but
like a ball
walking around the tower would be like
whoa
yeah like bro it's a little much like
we've been slaughtering each other for
centuries like you need to be isolated
in this little governmental mobile
command center thing where we we're
getting uh u.s vanguard government all
right let's see what we're doing here
yeah listen we got to do we lakshimi was
on to something
you got to be careful you let the child
these days i'm just joking but at the
end of the day i thought it was i
thought it was a good decision that the
helm was where the hell was and i like
that it's kind of they like government
they're like they're doing things the
citizens kind of know but not all the
dough and that's where the real stuff's
going on in there
i heard it here first cog is a fan of
apartheid
he wants to implement it in the tower
like i said separately
[Laughter]
demonetized before oh we want to go
ahead and cross that threshold
he wants the small one to go to separate
schools
[Laughter]
mobile command center was cool i felt
like they were addressing the weirdness
of the fact that the towers become
irrelevant and that we're all just
hanging out the helm and they're like
it's activated it's mobile command
center functionality and i'm like okay
so we were on a ship the whole time i'm
kind of confused by that but all right
uh works for me
works for me like for me that was one of
those rumors i heard when people pulled
like game assets at one point people had
really thought the helm
like had detachable geometry like it was
meant to a while i heard that rumor and
then finally when it was like
saw the pictures in the trailer saw that
it was uh
literally parked outside the moon i was
like finally took off thank you so i was
like i thought that was cool shout out
to gaming forte real quick
salute gentlemen feels good to see
hunter master races the pinnacle of dps
once again hashtag shameless plug
looking forward to all of your opinions
of course thank you for the support sir
yes that's a great podcast with the
forte but not the king of guardian games
you gonna have to watch my golden
bracelet
i don't i don't know where is the statue
in the tower i can't even see it it's
too small oh yeah okay you can't see it
i haven't seen it since the thing was
actually put in the tower three years
ago so you're getting right on guardian
games or
you know they're hard listen
oh my god
what what color is your uh your butt
towel is it is it gold what color is
that well i'm just curious i'm wearing
the heiress armor so i can earn more of
that
yeah it's already gone right
yeah do it away
honestly the hunt of those three the
hunter one's the best anyway because it
has like so many medals along the bottom
for the decoration that one looks
definitely the coolest for sure
um
so yeah helm takes off and
leviathan what you were saying is back
and it seems to have been
uh corrupted
the derelict leviathan is the name now
seems to have been corrupted and we've
got interactions with the nightmares
because it seems to be attracted to the
pyramid ship on the moon
and so far we haven't gone to the moon
it's all been actually inside the
leviathan so that was actually a
surprise to see
and this is where you know some people
are going to have the debate of is it a
reused asset is it the fact that we got
a new a destination coming with a season
is it a way for them to bring a
destination back for a season um before
we actually get to the activities are
you guys
liking what you've seen so far is it
enough or do you think that it's just
like is it an easier thing for them to
bring back
or is it a nice surprise were you guys
at landing on the fact that leviathan is
a new destination for a season
and also seems like where we're going to
be doing a lot of our seasonal stuff
draft let's go first
um
i am
i'm disappointed in pretty much
everything about the season so far that
i've seen um and i include so i'll just
stick with what you asked which was the
leviathan is the destination um i had
wondered if when they put all the stuff
in the vault they had mentioned that
their plan was to take some of it out
later later on and um i had kind of
wondered if this was their seasonal plan
was to like highlight certain areas and
like remix them and
you know it looks like they took all the
assets they made from destiny 2 vanilla
and all the assets they made from shadow
keep and just sort of like
you know merge them together uh and so
you're just you're going to the same
places so i'm not super
impressed with that i also don't like
that
all of it's there but not
not all of it is used they kind of just
use that main lobby area like the area
that we spent the most time in during
that
raid if you're if you were doing it
properly um and then you visit those
other rooms basically just to sort of
open chests and kind of explore and
stuff and
i'm just getting deja vu man feels like
feels like the moon accidentally had a
baby with the leviathan and i'm just
sort of walking around opening chests
like back in d1 when i was farming
it's just a crazy
crazy uh the most destiny thing that
they possibly could have done um and i
get it you know like it's a season they
didn't have to add a new location they
didn't have to do all the stuff i get
what they're trying to do but um
you know
resources are limited yada yada all the
excuses we always make but it doesn't
mean that it's particularly exciting and
i wasn't excited to go back to this
place it also feels like it wasn't gone
that long ago i don't know menagerie to
me was like
yesterday
and ashrae wasn't that long ago you know
what i've been kidding
it's been like five seasons but you know
five seasons so that's a little over a
year
that was
five seasons since the location left but
i think minute like menagerie was before
that right because that was season eight
more under 16 so two years yeah yeah
i mean for me you're different only
because
i'm so for the lore but like to me like
i'm at the point now like destiny has
finally got me into this place where i'm
actually here for where the logo goes as
opposed to the gameplay loop that it's
still
the it's all the gun plays and the way
the game plays always going to be fun to
me and and the things you can do but i
want to see where they go so he's always
been interesting to me callous has
always been interesting to me i've
always liked the location i always
you know mean lord league gaudy gold
opulent stuff so it gave me they played
with my nostalgia because when i got it
there i'm like ah i did miss this you
know what i'm saying i'm running around
you go in the castellam you go to
different parts and you see the changes
that they've made right they've they've
updated you know the royal
bats and the pleasure guards you're like
oh yeah that's where i did the dogs at
and stuff like that so for me it was
more
i admit they i was very caught in my
feelings for nostalgia because i did
really like leviathan for the time we
did have it and then the way it started
up and to see where it's going to go
with callus but this is where now i do
align with travis is the more
we'll get into the activity specifically
but the more you start doing it and then
it starts to the nostalgia wears a
little
and then you start to see the scope and
you're like hmm
is this gonna be enough
and and how are they going to
honestly sustain us for a long period
now to your point e final point i'll say
is that
we know they're gonna do tune in next
week you know narrative team
it's going to stop step step 10 of 66.
you know
tune in next week whatever you're going
to see you know all that but
the narrative is so good now
it allows me to say okay you know what i
love what y'all doing with storytelling
but yeah for some like travis said is
they're gonna be like yo there's
leviathan y'all y'all remix leviathan
they get really rick's shadow keep and
put it together and say again
some people gonna say and that they they
not wrong if they're not happy with that
that's what i would say
e where yet
uh yeah i mean i've played a lot of it
over the last couple of days so i get
both aspects uh we'll get to the story
mission here in just a little bit
that's where i think this is shining so
far
the story the narrative they're telling
um basically deeper character
development kind of understanding
history of some of these characters
kind of seeing currently we're seeing a
state of one it seems like with the
other two future weeks we might be
seeing more historical stuff that we
haven't ever seen before so they're
getting to tell cool stories with this
as a
you know as a vehicle to tell the
stories that i like and appreciate and
kind of you know unique little throwback
encounters the way the first mission was
done but when you get to the main
activity
that's where the scope of the season
if this is the focus of most of what
we're doing as i'm working through
like trying to find all these bosses and
just like these little hidden nooks um
i'm kind of seeing the scope of it
thank you for the baby the baby
yeah
i watched a video yeah baby calluses
there are there are four this week and i
don't know if there's gonna be two or
three weeks of those but yeah we'll have
a little collection there um
but yeah
yeah there's little little bobble heads
oh you ain't seen the little body little
calluses they little red yeah there's
little there's four little bobble heads
in there cute there you go you find them
on the ship yep
they go toward a triumph
uh yes yeah it'll be
teddy already has them you know that
scavenger hunt nice yup uh
yeah it's like services for me it's like
um
i wish there was more of the ship
and i think there has to be somewhere
because of the trailer when i sat there
and broke down frame by frame
there's more in there now maybe it's
just from the missions i don't know
because the missions went to a different
place than the activity does the
activity has the castellam the gardens
and the pools
uh the mission was different for sure uh
and there was more of the underbelly
exploration i wish
or maybe this is something that they do
a little later and crossing my fingers
hope but you know
not entirely sure expecting it either i
wish the whole leviathan was mostly
explorable at this point because
there are certain points we've seen in
the trailer where i think are going to
come from story missions if i think
through it now
because i know there's the room with the
callus robots post where you would
finish the leviathan actual raid beat
callus go underneath and get your loot
there's something down there for an
interaction
um
and that just may be part of the weekly
story mission there's also
like the underbelly with like
the tree like the underbelly with the
trees where you'd like be crawling or
walking on the little pipes up above i
remember like one of those rooms i saw
somewhere else so there there are a
couple shots i've seen that make me
think we're gonna explore more of it
i'm hoping
somewhere i don't know if they're gonna
like shift the leviathan in a weekly
basis kind of the way they do like a
dreaming city rotation if they did that
that would give it a little more life to
see if you got to explore a couple more
areas than you were doing you know their
exploration and the enemies and all that
stuff is nice but
yeah if it's just like the gardens and
the pools and then the castellan for the
main event i'm going to be kind of done
with most of that here outside of just
farming for activities
like this week
so if you got
you got a question from the legends in
the in the chat today legendary tom
warren
in the building thank you very much
do we think the leviathan is reprised
raid coming back next season
that would be
i think people would be disappointed if
it was
now if they said here is leviathan and
the three raid lairs
maybe as a as a bonus at some point
somewhere i could see them maybe doing
that because if they brought back the
leviathan we're probably going to see
most of the entire destination
i would like to see them used like bring
the raid backs just because they were
fun encounters and stuff you know maybe
you got random loot this time too but if
we don't get you know either the siva
raid or king's fall which i'm blanking
on the name of the other one wrath of
the machine if we don't get one of those
i would be very i think a lot of people
would be disappointed because most
people rank either of those if not both
of them above most of everything that
happened on the leviathan i would guess
some people hate crown leviathan you
know some people have that's like it's
one boss fight and then the other two
are raid lair so if you get
i don't know so i was like i don't think
that would be the reprised raid just
because i think that would be a bit of a
slap to some people
um who are hoping for that one that's my
opinion
i i have a similar opinion which is that
i thought i think like lots of us that
the reason the narrative team and the
bungie developers were so hyped about
the season is because they were going to
start using every season to tell a
consistent story and it was going to be
all focused around what's going on with
the traveler or sorry with the
the um
disciple
the witness thank you geez there's so
many
so many uh vague names for you know
vaguely creepy uh characters
um
yeah the witness i thought it was going
to be all about the witness and all
about the pyramid and they were just
going straight forward
for it and um it seems like with this
leviathan pivot i'm now convinced that
every season is just going to be
incongruous completely
you know because self-contained out of
nowhere so
the fact that the leviathan has returned
makes me even more confident the next
season is going to be something
completely unrelated and it's going to
have a completely unrelated raid maybe
from maybe they'll bring
the uh not the leviathan um the dr
dreadnought back and we'll have the fall
raid or you know they'll bring back the
the other half of edz or not edc other
half of the cosmodrome that they cut out
several seasons ago so that they can put
a wrath of the machine in there um
something like that i can just see that
happening more than i could see um them
just doubling down on leviathan that
would be a crazy pivot if they were like
all right witness witness and the witch
queen and now three seasons are just
leviathan oops all leviathan we're going
to reprise all the old raids and yeah
that would just be crazy to me so i i
i'm more confident from this that the
next raid is just going to be
something completely different different
story um it's been a while since we've
seen the fallen could easily be that
which queen was already hive it'd be
kind of weird to go back to king's fall
or crota's end even um so yeah i think
it'll probably wrap the machine
something totally different yeah i agree
i i think shout out to tom again he said
he uh definitely strange they bring back
basically everything leviathan for the
engine i think divide i got is that the
assets are being used
sparingly like to each point like
there's certain parts that are
completely cut off that are not fully
connected how we know it and it's it's
fully constructed form and i i'm with
you trav i think dramatically it would
be overkill and like you said like they
seem to be wanting to do that legends
playlist right where it's separate and
they don't have to narratively tie
vogue and you know whether it be king's
fall or whatever they just say hey this
is your old favorite it's coming back
this is separate it has nothing to do
with nothing and i think if they did
bring it back right now i would be some
i mean for like say for example the next
season because most likely you think e
it would be the the next season we'd get
a legends because we got the dungeon
this one yeah
eighteens or eight nineteen's a dungeon
they've already said that
right yeah so that that's that's what
i'm thinking so yeah we'll see we'll see
what happens but um you know overall
yeah i i i like that it came back i'm
just concerned about
how they're going to expand this
activity if we're going to get into
containment right now let me know and
all that yeah no i mean that's that's
kind of the piece of i mean i'm with you
guys it's like in what tom said he's
like it's definitely strange they'd
bring back everything in the leviathan
for the engine changes just to blow it
up again and i would hope
this is them getting away from some of
the vaulting situation again like give
and take give and take but again
i don't think they would bring in the
leviathan just to remove it this is one
of those things where if they did the
work on the leviathan to bring it in
we're gonna have story beats in there
we're gonna have an activity in there
it feels like this should stay for a
while
and if they manage to remove the
leviathan at the end of this year for
lightfall
that's a lot of work for an entire
destination
like the moon came it's still here
dreaming city is still here like europa
like the planets we've got have been
staying around so if they brought the
leviathan i don't think it's like
you know gonna get as you say exploded
with lightfall per se because the work
would go into that for a fairly short
amount of time of like nine months per
se so that's what i think it will
or will remove other destinations to
keep the new leviathan in there but i
feel like that's the model now is like
you create seasonal content it stays
there until the next major expansion and
then when the next major expansion comes
you pull out some stuff maybe not the
exact stuff you just finished making but
you roll it out somewhere to get the
game back to a you know more of a
skeleton so that you can put new stuff
in it yeah i mean like stuff like psyops
battlegrounds that would go away
and again the destination truly is where
like the activity takes place so maybe
if this is most of what it is we'll get
to in a second
maybe it is more of a temporary thing
but it is weird like they reuse
destinations like they'll reuse scarlet
keeper they'll reuse the edc like this
whatever that place is like one of the
dead like one of the landing zones for a
psyops battleground still use that area
for it but then you know they can strip
it out and just have the alternative to
bring an entire new thing into the game
would seem weird for it to just bail in
nine months but they do remove seasonal
content so if they have a story reason
for it maybe it does get blown up who
knows just going to be weird
one last point i do think they cheat
enough because
i know we we're going to get into the to
the narrative thing but bro the the
garland was kind of like a mission
yeah like like it was a mission like
like like so to me it's like they're
bringing it in these like weird pieced
off smallish kind of ways like they're
using this the whole thing but in
that's why i'm saying like when it comes
to the final calisthenic encounter and
where the robots are
that
has kind of a similar portal to the one
you jump through for the gauntlet ring
and that i saw a little trailer so if
that's just one of those things where
you go fight something you pop back and
do like if that's just one of those
mission teleporters we may not get to
see this whole thing which is yeah i
think a missed opportunity if we can't
just go to the cast elem which we'll get
to in a sec and just
explore the whole damn thing like why
can't i land outside and go explore the
whole thing and maybe that is more into
what travis is saying that it is a
temporary destination because they
brought back pieces pieces like confined
in certain areas it's not everything so
yep
uh but i know you want to talk about
nightmare containment so we got a new
activity this is basically a public
event uh it's got three waves which kind
of reminds me of what was the one on
mars old mars
escalation protocol
yeah so it's like something it's got
tears and waves to it basically um
and it's all packed within the castellum
so previously if you hadn't done this
before the leviathan was where the raid
took place the first encounter to
head off where you were supposed to go
for the week was from the castellam now
we're spending all of our time killing a
bunch of guys in there there's a lot of
enemies we're never short for enemies to
kill oh yeah
so enemy density in a small space maybe
that's not a bad thing but generally
what do you guys think of
this activity
yeah
i was a little disappointed as soon as i
launched it because
when i launched it i was like wait a
minute it's the same activity and
there's two versions of it
it was like containment and then what
was it run around or something like you
know
what's the other terminology that's what
you don't have an exploration yeah like
it's just called castellan because
they're sort of containment yeah it was
check it out or do the mission i was
like what like it just threw me off i've
never seen them do that and check it out
was the default setting
what is this the main one yeah yeah so i
did i did version check it out first let
me see what's going on and then happened
to be a containment going on right when
i landed for the first time so i was
like okay you know it was just weird i
never seen them do that so that's where
it got me to question like
man is this gonna be enough for cause
like we gonna live in here for a lot
don't get me wrong you know the the
levatin in theory
is big but the leviathan that we getting
this remixed one is not like you go down
you go to the little where the dogs are
at and then i was looking out doing my
little was it
now they got the thing with the keys and
you know go by the foot of greatness
yeah the little clue of opulent keys and
stuff yeah go by the chandelier on the
left side of and i'm like okay all right
running around you know there's little
nooks and crannies but not to the extent
of the true leviathan no concrete like
you know how we really would move around
i will say again nostalgia cog
did like going into where the bass was
to see the chandeliers that we destroyed
it felt like they gave the illusion that
we ran through this before like we
destroyed him and and i i gonna lie i'm
a huge callus fanboy so i like him
talking to uh
you know get fat from shrek that what
are you here for i've just lured you in
and i'm gonna scare you with the
nightmare obvious i like his foolishness
he's opulent he's over the top he's all
about the type of villains and
foolishness i like so again i'm biased i
like going through memory lane but yes i
am concerned
that you do this activity
you do you shoot the little four
darkness things you run around you kill
the ball scythe was cool it looked great
it was cool it was cool
whatever
i did that i like sky better
[Laughter]
just hates when i mispronounced words
like he discussed
oh bro i'd do it purposely because he
like it bothers him
he's a very particular individual but um
yeah like i just i'm just getting
dressed
after a week here it's fine we love you
we love you and then it was like at the
end of it it was just like okay you get
the chest but then there's this little
spinny thing but you don't have 500 of
the things to get it and i'm like all
right and i'm supposed to both i'm
supposed to go back to the helm and
start the loop and then i can't i can't
focus the engrams it's just weird it was
just i don't know i'm i'm not hating it
but i'm worried about how long i'm going
to enjoy this but after i get over my
nostalgia i'll give it to you guys
uh
travis hugo because i've spent probably
a good amount of time in there so i'm
just curious what yeah
yeah i've also spent a pretty good
amount of time there um
continuing what i said earlier about me
being disappointed about everything
about the season i'm also disappointed
in this matchmade activity which
actually isn't a match made activity
which is
i feel like we're we took a step
backwards there right now we're not even
getting a six page uh six person
matchmade activity we're getting you can
drop into a playlist of a open area that
apparently is more likely for you to end
up in a group but actually not not 100
because i've dropped in there plenty of
times and i'm like i'm the only dude
here what's going on uh so that's
happened uh too many times to count and
uh yeah the actual activity of what
you're doing it's you know you're just
shooting stuff
shooting nightmares
that's really all it is
they even chose you to do the standoffs
in the exact same places we used to do
them yeah which is like in front of each
of the doors it's like there's four
doors four places you can do the
standoffs
yeah i've been here before they just put
a spooky flare on it it feels more like
the festival of the leviathan yeah
that's what it makes you think of it
makes me feel
it's festival of the leviathan that's
literally what i was going to say it
makes me feel like this is a a live
service
uh like holiday event that's what makes
me feel like so
this is yeah dude all right and then and
then who and then who's the boss at
least this week
another reused boss like here's this
dude the the guy we killed in uh
yeah so it's it's i i feel like the
the nightmares thing is my least
favorite thing that they do because it's
just like hey dude we already built this
asset the dlc i mean that's basically it
right it's like hey here's crota
remember him we still have his asset and
it's like
this time we're going to make him
shadowy everybody he's crota you got to
kill him with sword and i'm just i'm
just like man
this is this ain't it bungie
i'm just i'm so surprised like how much
momentum they had coming off witch queen
you know what asset they could have used
light bearing hive
where were they like
they built those whole characters they
were
super well received i like them
not at all in use here
it's crazy so i i just um
i don't i don't know what they're doing
yeah i'm just confused i think this that
enemy type is so good but i think
they're struggling on how to include it
lore wise because it's so connected to
saboteur but i'm with see that might be
they need to figure it out i mean that
might be why they go hive next season
though to get back to that as quickly as
they can because if they can incorporate
those in some way people do enjoy that
type of enemy as opposed to 14 000
champions
how's your feeling running around
so yeah i mean i'm with you guys like
i've been doing it just to try and find
all the little alcove bosses and try and
track down and check all the little
triumphs to see where they are because
making a lot of content but yeah i mean
i've
run the loops around the castle
way too many times at this point
and if that's what the whole season
holds for doing that to build up your
vestiges of dread which don't seem that
hard to come by anymore
um if you go look for them for a little
while they're not that hard to get but
then it's like oh i've got some of those
to spend let me go back in there and do
the public event which takes you know
like 15 minutes to go through tier one
all the different waves take a little
break go to tier two
take a little break go fight the boss
break the look you know do the little
shield break things
it's
it is gonna get old fast
and i think it's one of those
that if they if it is only in the cast
alum which is my worry i have no reason
to think that they would move it around
caught me 2b i was like no but it was
like if even even if they rotate it
would it's the one room that makes sense
for it so like if they did it in the
gardens for example there might be a
couple little nooks where you could do
this but it still would feel probably
very weird same thing with the the pools
at least has probably a better setup for
it there's kind of like ice three
different areas but even both of those
are so much smaller confined they don't
have the way the space is set up in the
castle where you would have three
different places and then a fourth for a
boss no other room looks like that so
it's like if that's where the public
event is the entire season
that's a lot of the same thing to do a
lot and you're kind of coming back to
season of the worthy with the public
event it is a
it's a public event yeah it's like
everybody enjoys the public
everybody enjoyed the mars public event
of escalation protocol for a while but
then when you went to try and go god i
don't want to go do seven waves of this
thing and it's not like a public event
that you can knock out quickly if you
jump into level like tier one and it's
just getting started you're like all
right 15 minutes later let me dunk these
500 that i've got and you know all good
gear but at some point if you get all
your craftables
for your weapon frames people are gonna
duck i mean at that point if you farm
enough in there to get the weapons that
you want
which you can get quite a few of them
and then you go run and get your opulent
keys like once people have their crafted
frames there's very little in there so
it is yeah
it's also i wanna i wanna piggyback on
something you said he bought which is
the castellam it's the only appropriate
place to hold that event in leviathan
but it's still a weird place it feels
like a lobby right it's like it wasn't
designed for like perfect analogy
it's it's like if your improv team got
locked out of their theater and so you
guys had to do your show like in the
hall you know in the street in like the
foyer or outside or somewhere and like
everybody forgive him everybody who's
attending the comedy show like knows
that this wasn't the original venue and
that you guys couldn't get access to it
and it's just got that like really
awkward low budget like theater kid
cringe that only theater kids can truly
own and harness
that's what it reminds me of it's just a
weird venue
it's like oh yeah uh come see my comedy
team we're gonna be performing in the uh
the uh the back store of a cake shop you
know and you're just like there's no
there's no way this is
not gonna work you know so
i i have problems with that and i also
um i hate that you can fail the activity
and it does not care the only thing you
don't yeah the only thing you do the
heavy ammo it's completely ambivalent
and you get a few less uh what is it
opulent umbrella energy when you finish
the boss so the first two tiers are do
you get a heavy full restock like ammo
restock for the next tier when it's the
final boss if you fail to kill him which
i've done actually like once yeah you
can still
you get like you know some probably a
blue out of the chest and then you also
get nightmare harvester you can still
pull from that but you probably will get
a little bit less but you can
technically
still like you don't truly fail that's i
didn't notice that as well yeah you
don't i've only done it once but you
don't actually fail let me ask you all
this how y'all feel about because i'm
indifferent i'm curious how y'all feel
about after
budgie post activity
making you go chase and run around for
something with a timer
like almost um
aerial zone vibes now not to the extent
but i'm just curious how y'all feel
about that okay so you you cool with
that oh no i hate it but it's perfect
it's perfect for destiny it is like
hey do the thing you you most despise
public events that feel completely
frivolous and and uh repetitive and and
then afterwards
go and open chests like you did in d1 do
the do the spin metal farm it's like i
said like everything about this
expansion this season is the most
destiny thing i've ever seen it's very
unbelievable seasonal season of the
destiny yeah it is it's what it should
be i i think um
it's aptly named as a season season of
the haunted this season is haunted by
all of destiny's past and
the engine is haunted the engine is
haunted by the limitations of this aging
engine and all the glitches and bugs
we're saying it is literally the season
of the haunted in the most literal sense
imaginable it's crazy to me guys it's
crazy i'm so down on the season i just i
i don't even know where to begin
odysseus is apparently sharing your
thoughts in chat there so he's
let me get the homies that was hilarious
he said my only issue is budgie
developer set a bad expectation by
saying this would be the best season in
destiny so far still a top lot of time
to make the save but disappointing right
now now i feel i feel forte's goal and i
think that that's where the sentiment is
i think i know where travis is going e b
you kind of feel the same we're just
worried like
okay
you know like so this is it you know
it's like you know the kid's all proud
it's like ta-da we're like oh that's
okay so what else is what else you got
going on you know kind of thing so i i
got to see but i i if it was to end
right now yeah nah nah that's not going
to be it that's not i mean
chad saying season the old we got
leviathan we got trespasser we got a
dick
but i mean literally that's it's the
season
it's the unvaulting of previous things
now
granted i will say like if next week
there's a shift in the leviathan where
the public event takes place we've got
other places to explore then i'll hold
my reservations but honestly the way
it's set up right now if this is like
again
that's like my dream is the fact that it
could move around and use more of the
actual space
if it doesn't
and this is what we've got and we've got
like
a fifth of the leviathan and then the
story takes you through the rest of it
you can replay the story missions sure
but like you can't just go get lost in
life that was the best part like hold on
i'm down here i'm in the armory where
the how do i get to the
the waterworks and all that like how do
you get around to the different places
you'd get lost
[Music]
and that's what i was when i saw it like
hoping and then i went and was like okay
and then i went the first time i was
like oh you know i'm at the the pleasure
gardens went down with the dogs i was
like okay cool i'm in here saw a couple
alcoves added for like a couple little
mini boss fights and stuff and enemies
responded like crazy and then i saw the
connection ran up there and then i
noticed when i went from the pools
the only place to go was back to the
castle and i was like we're missing some
stuff we're missing some stuff yo shout
out to tko he said the icing on top will
be the new dungeon taking us to all the
raid layers
that hopefully doesn't happen because
it'll just it'll just be spire of stars
oh
god this season
anything wrong all i'm saying is that
like you will see over me turn it's like
it i will be so disgust and don't let
them lock
the snickers that time he's going to
need the snickers
no really valuable thing that i want
behind it it inspire oh god val calor at
all
that's my nightmare that's what it's
season of the haunted for me it's truly
a nightmare
the way i think of it you with your your
just like
your
naive audience no i know
this guy
i don't expect it i don't expect even
even as a dream it hurts me to hear you
say those things as like a hope
just because it's like so obviously not
gonna happen but i just i'm just like
even on bad seasons guys
the best week is week one when
everything feels new and
even even on seasons where we end up not
liking whatever activity we're doing at
least that first week we're like okay
it's fun i'm having a good time i worry
a little bit about it being burnt out
and then like by week three we're like
okay i hate the season already right but
we're talking like this dlc came out two
days ago
and we're already over it
it's
four weeks from now we are gonna be
hating this deal like we're gonna hate
this season we've got to and i just i
think that they're they're thinking that
maybe the story can carry them and i
agree with you guys like the story's
probably the best part but i'm still
disappointed with the story because i
feel like they're they're focusing on
stuff that doesn't really matter it's
not they're not doing what i was hoping
that they were doing which is start
building momentum toward the next
expansion and talking about the witness
and stuff that's going on with the
traveler and this totally seems
incongruous it's just like a random
you know misadventure through what's
going on with leviathan and callus and
nothing feels more frivolous than
catching up with all callus and and
going back to the old location and i
just don't
it's it's not what i was hoping that
they were building to with all of the
narrative team being stoked about this i
i love the crow as much of as as the
next person but um i it it doesn't feel
great to just see him reflecting on the
same stuff he's been reflecting i agree
with you however many seasons are going
like i agree who am i yeah i agree
we've heard
yeah no no i'm with you i'll jump in
because um
you know
i am a little narrative team gets a a
plus to me or like this the last one is
a year and a half two years almost you
know they've been killing it but i will
say if i had to put one knock is the
crow
storyline to me is dragging it's like we
know you want to do the redemption but
every season they're putting him through
some more torturous thing or some
tumultuous thing and i get it the
redemption and i get it to me the best
part i mean let's get right into it you
know
if we did the mission you know the older
and solve um
you know nightmare him talking to
himself okay cool you know him being
totally dejected to not be able to
participate while we're fighting in the
um in the gauntlet okay whatever but i
like the i like the mission i thought
the mission structure was actually
really cool they had the unstoppable
kind of guy chasing you how you put the
the the mechanisms down i i love that
mission it's kind of it
reusable aspect a little bit with the
spores kind of like the um what was the
ship the mission that we did that that
went away that that where
callas's ship that
glycon right so it had glycon elements
had all the little element and then they
had the the what you call it the um the
gauntlet at the end with the fight with
one of the uh the thing but i want to
say like yeah
so i will say like
i am getting annoyed with it with him in
the like i want
please if after this season i would love
the conclusion of his arc to truly let's
go now let's go we we get it you're not
the same person anymore you're going to
prove it the best part though i will
give them this
did you guys listen after the mission to
the terminal
on the side of the crown of sorrows and
the conversation between him and amanda
yep
that was fire yes i like that cause she
was like yo bro you lied to me all this
time you know what i'm saying like you
what were you gonna tell me what you
know what the situation was kind of
thing because they had built a
friendship and once she she when she
said the cold-blooded line like
you're not i'm your friend like no you
killed my friend yeah and i was like oh
oh man like a man she had that little
spicy accent like i was like go ahead of
it tell him i was like oh i felt that
one so again they're doing a good job i
just want crow's storyline to really go
we know they're gonna go with um
uh zavala at some point okay and i'm
done yeah kyle's the one i need
that's the one i need because i know
zavala's gonna have some deep personal
back in the day when he was a thing but
i need to know the whole
daughter thing with him like what cause
she's being extra and i wanna know what
the fears are so that's the one i'm
looking forward to but to travis's point
self-contained story and we know this is
not advancing the arc other than
eventually callus will be
you know some helper of the you know of
the witness maybe and i just can we
fight the real catalyst can we get that
let's let's see i'm trying to calm down
they got a lot to prove
right now go ahead jeff
i figured it out guys
i know why they're focusing so much on
crow
and him turning back into uldren they're
going to make his ark be a
transformation where he turns back into
uldren solve so that they can
resell us the forsaken king
exact same story he's going to
they're reselling us the forsaken
campaign
that's how it comes back man they're
pulling it out of the content vault
that's gonna be beautiful old you're
gonna win he gonna be his true self
yeah that's good
you know what i am ultra soft i've got
an idea i'm gonna go and release all of
the i can't
get back
that's right i'm gonna bring back the
scorn it's gonna be the exact same
campaign like beautiful beautiful he
saved us max eight save us man give me
some power i need some positivity right
now come on save your decease uh
no like honestly the way this no that's
not what i'm saying not what i'm doing
no no i'm not doing that no that's not
what i'm saying no i will say when i
played the story mission first time i
had to replay it again like you'll
replay it a couple times if you have the
currency you can spend first time i
played through i did enjoy it uh i
enjoyed going through the underbelly
have you talked to the automaton for
callus
if not in sever right after the little
pipes
go to the right
it's not that far to get to just like
replay the mission go to the right and
listen to him the voice actor for kallus
i don't know if it's the same one or
different delivers his part
really well through that like automaton
robot he's just like speaking to you
through it really he has a really good
set of voice lines in there and
i i don't know if it's the same voice
actor it just felt like it had a deeper
gravel to the voice it just had more
weight
to his voice which means i don't know if
it's the same or if they have a like
same or different voice actor either way
if that voice is something that we face
at some point that's a good thing
because the way those lines were
delivered the weight to it i like the
way that kalas sounded
like
yeah go explore the ship that's fine
it's like
like i listen to what he says it's very
it's it's interesting uh but i just like
the feel of the delivery which was good
and there's going to be one of those as
new rad said there's six of those so
there's an automaton every week so
you're going to be getting like
basically messages from callus every
week
so wait where do i go for this so when
you boot up sever we have a beating you
know
you can replay it you can go replay it
multiple times because the currency you
get the bound presence we'll get to the
currencies in a minute
travis is favorite
uh but the currency you get you can earn
more of those by chance during the week
and if you do you can go back in there
and play through it again and turn them
in so all right so i go through there
where do i get this at the time of time
when you go through you know remember
like you were crouched and you went
through the little pipes
yes yes like literally right when you
pop out of a pipe go right
when you're done with the pipes go to
the right and he's just like chilling
he's like laying in a corner and he
speaks through the robot he is he's
basically dead
hey look at you he looks exactly like
that's why my thumbnails are robots just
like ball that's why he looks like that
so i gotta do that right um
but yeah it's like i i'm enjoying the
voice actor
like i think the voice sector for crows
doing a very good job i think what he's
doing for the lines for crows he's doing
like a good delivery for him kind of
showing the anguish he's going through
also you've got all dirt on the other
side but i'm also with you guys
at some point is this going to end
because we've had mara deal with his
things and then he messed up with like
season of the chosen and seasoned of the
hunt like he has been this undertone
character for quite a while
i mean it was hunt you found him chosen
he was dealing with kaidal splicer he
had less to do in splicer i feel like he
don't think it was around as much lost
obviously came back in and then we had
witch queen where what was he quiet or
less well no risen he was huge
yeah risen he was massive and then now
this one again so it's like they're
using crow a lot which isn't a bad thing
if there is a payoff
but at some point we do actually need
some kind of payoff he can't just have
you know this season's drama where he
stubs his toe into the family guy
like he you get your payoffi when you
play forsaken too
i love it
yeah that's just that's kind of the
thing it's like and that's why it will
be nice to see like kaido as you said i
want to know what's going on with kaidel
gaul
theoretically because you know callous
is the bigger piece of this because we
got gaul set in the background it's like
what's the interaction between those two
i'm really curious i think i i think i
could figure out
though so i was like and then zavala
that was his end goal see odd or
whatever her name was
um that's like apparently supposedly as
well as you know ex-wife or something
like love interest of some kind that
there's probably a very small
like lore piece too
um
so i will be curious about those for a
little backstory but as you said
i wish the story would progress late
if you ever watch like you know a
like a syndicated tv show where there's
like 24 episodes
every so often you start an episode and
you're like oh this is a filler episode
yeah and i'm not saying this is like a
filler
completely because there's like some
undertones with crow and you've still
got kyle and zaval and you've got like
this little like band working together
now we added aeris so we've got like a
new one this season but it is
what
no finish finish it thought first no and
it's just like but also it's like
which queen happened and then now
callus showed up but as you said there's
no hive guardians uh you know the witch
queen stuff isn't there
beyond light still sitting way back
there with elsie and anna just not doing
anything they just showed up in like one
little cinematic there's just again it's
it's when you think a little like if you
think too hard about it for too long you
realize there's a whole bunch of dagger
and stuff out there and you're like
there's one more thing now we've added
to it without resolving much
so no i agree i agree i think it's a
good point i i want to do want to give a
shout out
surprisingly to eris
um i feel at first i didn't know where
she was going with the ooga booga seance
thing at first i was like okay what are
we doing what are we doing why are we
getting our indian style feet bent knees
bent hands together okay what are we
doing but then
i out even though i'm annoyed with the
crow situation
i like the way she's counseling him yeah
because as a person who's been severely
haunted yeah she's not like this right
yeah she she to me speaking how i always
be like bro you got to let this go like
you you're going to be debilitated your
entire life if you you know it's going
to be a process it's like he's like this
brooding depressive figure
oh yeah
somebody said that chat earlier so yeah
and it's just like bro you she she spoke
to me i was like i'm speaking to her as
a player like bro you got to get through
this otherwise we're not going to be
able to think and then at the end of the
mission you know he's like i'm sorry i
let you down
yeah yeah like damn it you didn't even
fight during the mess you did nothing
you stood there while i'm fighting for
my life going through american ninja
warrior again with the with the fallen
captain thing and i'm like what are you
doing bro like so we have got issues
with that part but yeah i wanted to say
that and then once we finish this thing
i do want to talk about the the part of
the season because i know we were kind
of down this season and rightfully so
all fair points but i do want to get to
the part when you guys finish um about
what i do like about the season and
again you know i'm lord sandbox lord
builds and i wanted your opinions on
solar 3.0 because there is a talk like
yo
this is you know not as good that's void
3.0 and then wait wait hold on i'm going
to get to you i want to know from the
titan perspective because i'm going to
tell you all from the warlock
perspective where i'm at with it but i'm
very curious how tight cause i feel in
titan's defense i'm gonna be nice
yeah i got the short change on stasis i
feel
when they did 3.0 yes how did y'all feel
about void 3.0 titan
so it was reasonable like the
overshield's been beneficial it's not
not like you know crazy exciting but
also like it is reasonable yeah i think
about travis so
my titan brothers how are y'all feeling
playing with the fragments now i know
it's early but what's your feeling of
titan solar 3.0
i have underwhelming i was like i've not
been experimenting that much i got i've
started doing the one thing that i
wanted to do i've been making sunspots
like a crazy person with my little
throwing hammer
like everything i can kill with that i
do i chunk the little hammer bank the
guys they're making sunspots it's
cooking wherever they are floor is lava
um those aren't as strong as they used
to be which is unfortunate um so i've
mostly been goofing around just like
literally like content in that so i
haven't gone deep into builds or
fragments or seeing what's so much there
uh travis feels like he's got a little
deeper on this one so we're getting out
of here yeah i spent i spent a lot of
time trying to make this good because
i'm trying to figure out is this going
to be part of the meta or whatever and
i'm just convinced it's not going to be
at least part of pvp it's not going to
be part of the meta but i also don't
really know why you would use it in pve
it
cooldowns are really bad on on titans um
the whole building up um what it scorch
and then ignition yeah
doesn't really give me the payoff i
would hope for um
it also requires like a lot of times you
got to use your super to actually ignite
and to get to that point yeah i'm i'm
still confused as to how many stacks of
scorch it takes to explain what they
tell me doesn't it doesn't really seem
like it's just behind the scenes there's
nothing on the there's nothing on the
enemies showing like a number or a bar
of or scorch or any debuff on the
enemies you don't see anything on them
so you're just like have i done enough i
don't know if i've done enough
building building a healing i've also
tried building like a healing one it's
not really feasible on the titan and
that's fine i mean i i realize the
titan's supposed to be 100
um you know building scorches ignitions
but i just haven't seen it really pay
off in any any super like exciting way
like if i'm playing crucible i would
much rather have my void build where
every time i put out my class ability i
get an overshield and yada yada i just
it feels a lot more versatile to me
i was worried
solar would be overpowered with like the
fact that it could heal and the fact
that it does damage over time and now
they're saying it explodes everything i
was like damn this is gonna be crazy and
it just at least in the titan i've been
i've seen my friend
the hunter main has a christmas hunt
where i'm like damn you guys are
crushing it but uh at least with the
titan i've i've
you know it's still early it's only been
two days but i really haven't
it hasn't clicked with me in a way that
void 3.0 clicked
i was like yep this is the way to do it
um
also i feel like the aspects aren't
they're not super exciting to me right
now um and the
the ones that were
unlocking as a community apparently
which is weird um we'll see if the we'll
see if those change the game but i also
hate the way that we've been getting
those aspects the fact that you just buy
them from like
yo we'll go to walmart and get your ass
back
man it's like yeah is
is this just because
people complain that aikora's not around
enough so they're like here we'll just
make her a vendor you go and she's a
yoga instructor and you're going to
meditate next time
well i was going to say though for
titans
i will say they made the resilience that
matter
resilience if you stack it all the way
up to 10
again i'm with travis that the barricade
with the overshield doesn't compare
having that ability to give yourself an
overshield and the healing doesn't feel
as close to comparable it is more of
like a dps build but if you go full they
change the stat if you go full 10 it's
40 damage reduction
so if titans lean into that more because
they're typically the class that usually
does for theirs 40 40 damage reduction
then you've got the 25 from the mod
that's solar and void this season
and then theoretically if you put
something up like they said laura lee
splendor if you put that on for better
healing that's a very tanky build
theoretically so i'll be curious to test
that one out a little bit but yeah the
40 i heard on like day one somebody just
checked their stats and all of a sudden
40 damage reduction
massively more it scales up like 20 to
40 in the last few levels it's pretty
fast so the resilience for a titan which
is usually the stat that if we want our
class item on any s like consistency we
can do that so that does help them a
little bit but i would say titans
overall i've been goofing around with
throwing hammers in the sunspots but
void felt changing you had volatile you
had weakened you had
like the overshield you guys had
stuff for you know invisibility is like
a game changer and then you had you know
uh what is that old god what is the
little
there were things like that that felt
different like the way the animations
changed the one for the titans when you
do like the wave and the slam very cool
but it's more show than function because
like okay hold on i gotta run back over
here i gotta get a running start i'm
gonna slide hit it and then wait for how
about half a second then i gotta slam
down
with the two the two double hammer slam
i will say that's an aspect it looks
cool
but it's like don't slam it yep yay
running loose in pvp with that i haven't
everyone have heard of this powerful
that's a one hit acquitter in pvp titans
running loose with that just got to give
y'all i don't wanna hear no lip about
the sun nose it was a handheld supernova
after what i see a couple of titans
it's not that it's it's no shatter dive
it's not like you can i don't know i i
we'll see we'll see it's too early but i
i just i don't think it's enough really
quit is enough it's not a game changer
because i mean how long ago was it that
the titans were shoulder charging people
and one not killing them
which was already a super like spammy
noob move that any anybody
could easily counter you know what i
mean so it's like whatever we're good
we're good long as you read it i'm good
yeah i mean dude if you're running
around shoulder charging people to get
kills in pvp i guarantee you your kd is
a 1.0 because all you're doing is you're
getting the kill and then immediately
getting shot or or not even getting the
kill and they're they're shooting you
with the shotgun as you charge toward
them so i don't know it just feels like
a more fancy version of that in few
people
so before i talk about the warlock
delegation um alex kilgore has a
question for you he said what was con
talk about what the what's the name of
the move with the two axis
okay there you go
that's what can we talk about yeah so
it's like you slide and you get a wave
of fire but you also start a jump and
then if you hit the button again then
you do the double slam and it's kind of
like the dead messenger it's like the
it's almost like a triple wave kind of
like the scythe almost right in front of
you it's a big
big smash in front of you and yeah it
does a lot of damage but like to line it
up i can't just like jump in the air and
go whatever i want to like a shadow it's
like all right so i gotta run around i
gotta be running
right i already gotta be like in motion
then i gotta slide then i gotta line it
up then i gotta jump and it's like
somewhere in that process they might
just boop me and i'm like all right well
okay so i was like it's it is one of
those
it feels cool in show and shout out to
the animation looks very awesome shout
out to the artist who did that but in
function for like an aspect it doesn't
feel like it's i'm in a grand master and
i'm going to use consecration no i'm
probably going to die trying it is what
that feels like
that's what that feels like because you
say there's a lot of steps to get to
what you want to execute is which i'll
say yeah it might be good for pve at a
low level but it's like run up slide
jump in the air and then you do the slam
and it's like okay so i killed like four
adds
and it took me you know eight seconds to
like line that all up and just at that
point it's like all right just get a
shotgun dude just get a fusion rifle
you'll kill everything it won't be a big
deal it's just
it's it's really for people who want to
stunt on the enemy that's really what
it's about
that's the breakdown for the walk i was
just going to say look at this pictures
apparently blade barrage though beast
yeah with the upgrade that's like one of
the best dps in the game right now crazy
they needed that they needed that i mean
for me it's so weird i think
we hunt the warlock delegation have some
net losses with so like solar's big for
warlocks yeah you know because it used
to be the top tree
and then here's the thing like the first
thing i struggled is
phoenix dive was my get out of jail free
card when you were bottom tree dawn
that is now like a specific class move
to replace
the rift
and that so i went with it just to see
how it works
and my only issue is that you throw a
rift down and you gotta sit in it right
this is like okay run
you do the move to phoenix dive and come
down it supposedly heals you and other
people but the healing is very quick it
doesn't last very long and it just gets
you it's no overshield got it they just
kind of get you back to full health
instantly but the thing i don't like is
that if you don't have class ability
you can't use it so that was kind of
like a all right a little net negative
there
now the other thing was on
the thing that i do like
bro snap
that's fire
that literally i don't i didn't
understand how they literally
like i didn't understand how the
ignitions worked at first and then i
found a couple of fragments to stack
them so that when you do it
and i got to be honest it's hard for me
to take off anything but some braces
are just stupid right now because you do
the thing you get the kill you get the
ignition then some braces already coming
did if you throw that aspect that makes
the the grenades more powerful there's
one that we have and bro it's like you
put a little lava thing like you throw
the solar grenade you know it poses
normally but then lava comes out and
it's shooting more people and it's
lasted longer yo the grenades solar
grenade is crazy with that thing and
heat rises man he rises it's really
it's really strong you jump in the air
um you do the thing and then you know
you get a little bit more air accuracy
and the other thing that i like about it
is if you get kills while heat rises you
extend it the typical thing that we've
been doing but the synergy with the snap
and certain exotics is really cool i i'm
with trav though i don't think
the what is it the f not the fragments
the ass what's the ones on the bottom
fragments are on the bottom aspects
specific okay so the fragments i don't
think are as interesting as void though
i think they're kind of very
okay we'll give you this because
everything with the warlock is like
ignite scorch and then this radiant
thing which is supposed to give you like
a little 10 dps
it's okay i mean obviously
it's early like trav said there's gonna
there's aspects that they're holding
that we gotta see you know i mean how
that works out but um i like it
i i gotta get the lee attacked what's up
taz yeah i gotta get the exotic legs i
heard the the legs or take takes it to
the next thing and i'm going to do a
video video to educate the world i see
fallouts outside man shout out to
fallout playing he's outside with his
warlock building shout out to our
vanguard update in cactus but it's early
for us i think there was potential we
did lose some things but overall it's
okay but i have to agree with you it's
not better than void 3.0 to me i think
void 3. was clearly still superior if i
had to rate it
i think for me it's just the fact of it
felt like void changed
more
like we got overshields that we could
take with us on the fly the animations
for the shield changed
this feels like almost what i expected
it to be the first time around is like
you can customize it but most of it's
still there and we tweaked a few things
not really anything felt
that different like now i said i could
use sunspots and i can have a throwing
hammer and you know it's a nice little
combination to play guys and get those
popping of more frequently all over the
place but
void was like
changing this is it was a game changer
like overshields invisibility was nearly
infinite you guys had
more stuff than you know what to do with
over there on the warlock camp and like
we were having fun like titans too
because then you had volatile and then
you had them explode and you had the
weakening grenade which was
you can have a grenade that just makes
them like take more damage straight up
that's hard to compete with
so it does feel
they don't feel equivalent yet again we
haven't seen all the builds there are
certain things maybe you can boost your
damage a little more with some of this
other stuff and radiant and other things
versus weakening it's you know buffing
and maybe the synergy of a team is the
idea here where eventually all this
stuff comes together after seeing this
though i have no idea what they're going
to do with arc i don't know if it's
going to be like more over the top like
void or if it comes in
kind of
you know a little bit of polish like we
got for the
for solar i don't know did any of you
guys get your new exotics yet just
for that okay no okay i gotta get that
law sucked you said the legs today right
i don't i don't know if somebody did but
okay probably checkable
okay
gotta check that out and check that
challenge travis is challenging these
1v1 bros in the in the chat room
so with the chat always putting it on
the line so i was going to ask do you
feel
um
well of radiance
where are you on that
um my
report card is incomplete
because i'm having too much fun
burning things
and doing the other stuff i haven't even
touched a healing grenade yet
like but i heard i will say this
in pvp
i shout out to dj again and um sinister
like
because of the the what is it the uh the
cool down on supers you know supers have
ranks now with the tears
yeah like
it's almost advantageous to do be like a
bubble titan bro and a well awareness
well of radiance bro
because you're getting that super fast
and you now can use them especially if
you're doing cap type points or cap
trials what we were doing but
i haven't done it yet i've i don't know
what the consensus is for my other
warlocks i don't know anybody chat who's
been playing well yet to know what it is
the only one i messed around the only
other build i messed around was dawn
chorus and that is strong single target
dps because it adds extra ignite on
everything it's super strong i got to
get those boots so i'm still there's a
lot of stuff i got to play with but i'm
just having so much fun with the sun
braces synergy and the uh claws of
almond cara synergy um with the snap and
igniting things and just getting
abilities back and radiance and shooting
power stuff all day so i'm having fun
i'm just burning stuff up you know but i
gotta i gotta lean into that when it
comes raid time and dungeon because you
know that's you yeah i know y'all gonna
need me for your little your little
wealth you
you already little warlock to get that
dps through so we gonna see
uh let's see what else we got so we got
the story mission we got the activity
and we got solar 3.0
and this is a week one now tomorrow is
the one that i think everybody's gonna
wonder
is tomorrow worth it
because some people are gonna wonder if
you didn't if you bought it separately
it's a 10 dungeon on its own if it's
just part of the season and the deluxe
edition then you know you didn't pay out
the
out the rear for it so
basically i think i've heard the name of
the dungeon and that's basically it we
don't know much
oh what's the name what's the name
spire of stars i was getting
[Laughter]
before tomorrow but by the time you
listen to this it's probably going to be
out anyway five three two one it's
called duality
the shotgun
the idea behind it i think is the
the good and bad more of the yin yang
type yeah the traveler and the pyramid
ship like it's the the two duality
because they make you do the same raid
again
spire of stars
he's out he's out of pocket
duality travis travis
is so excited about it now
i'm sorry guys
you want to roll today bro
i can't stop you like you're just going
to let it go you got to let it play with
the rubble of course
i'm sorry guys i just the the reskins
that are killing me out here with these
things
can we talk about how ridiculous
trespassing is though
dressmaster feels good
when you can learn it's great when you
can line that thing up and you get that
extra boost going just like
in pve it's easy pvp a little harder to
put those together but pve you just
start mowing down ads
also a returning weapon yes we talked
about this we said season to the old we
covered it earlier
you're haunted by this season seasonal
haunted is such a good name for the
season it's really so so eat let me ask
you this though
do you think it was a mistake for them
to give us trespasser an ark
exotic
not during arc 3.0 yeah that's kind of
weird right
i mean they can't go like all solar
because we did get a solar boat thank
god there's a legendary one out there
you can't get
but
yeah that feels weird right here's your
season pass weapon for solar 3.0 season
archive and it's pointing the wrong
direction can we fix that please
yes
even in my preview when i was going
through the website i was like oh it's
facing the wrong direction yeah but it
totally is an art charge part so is the
first part kinetic and then it's arc or
what and i was like nope there's just a
few things in the game right now that
are facing the wrong direction and i
don't know why it's the new weapons too
because yeah a couple of follow hollow
denial the trace
yeah trav you got any of the um
new new stuff yet you haven't tried
anything i i got one of the what is it
the oh i got it all straighter oh sorry
anybody get anybody get any new you know
well no i use the mini tool uh which is
pretty decent okay i actually got two
red frames of those so i'm probably
going to try to craft that pretty soon
um i used the drang i think
yeah the ones that came out that was
raven about that guy that that gun is
really good i think that's going to be
in the meta for sure okay uh
getting them scouts yet traffic scouts
they need those scouts i mean scouts i
play pvp so it's like a scout yeah
a
a scout rifle is three legendary shards
is what it is
[Laughter]
anyway
but yeah mini tool and drang are the
highlights i've gotten so far all right
what about you what highlight weapons
you got
i mean i've been using the linear fusion
just because it seems to come up for
like bounties a lot so i've been using
the new the hollow denial the void
linear fusion um
and again this is that one i actually
got one that has a trait on it says
defeating a void debuffed target grants
an overshield so in theory that's
something that plays with a void 3.0
but yeah i was like that's just making
void look better they try to keep it hot
even though they do yeah
callous mini tool can get a perk
i don't think i've got one with it where
it can get scorched
yeah i want that i want those guns that
got that perk i know what you talk about
it's like it's a solar
thing now let me ask you this um because
i've been having fun
with the machine gun buff
i've been using thunderlord like crazy
person oh how's that done
thunderlord feels good
i also played a couple matches a game
but because i was trying to knock out
some seasonal challenges for xp
i don't advise that but it's there um
but i will say i definitely got hit with
xenophage a couple times and i was like
oh yeah that's bad that still hits hard
so xenophage don't forget about that
thing because it's still good it hits
hard now well it didn't get the boss
buff the 40 for champion it's gonna
smash so it's gonna do it's gonna do
some work
yo the oneness kilimit for me are 360
legendary 360 rpm the heavy impact
framework yeah like correct no that's
not even corrective measure corrective
measures i got an archon thunder right
now with auto loading and just ran page
and i'm like melting those nightmare
dudes in the um
in the costello like
like better than a rocket and i'm like
yo the the legendaries seem to benefit
more
outside i haven't tested though i
haven't tested though and i haven't
tested it
it's crazy works
i gotta grab when you get that lightning
to come down and you kill like six ads
at the same time it works it definitely
works
yeah the small stuff dies fast and then
again yeah if you pick up the little
nightmare unstable essence and you go
after one of the guys and you've got
like a bit of a damage boost oh it's
yeah they'll they'll go down pretty fast
which is i just want to take this
opportunity to point out that
thunderlord has
no thunder involved in the weapon
100
lightning like the lightning lord
is the lightning lord
[Music]
yeah i got that that rocket that bump in
the night
i feel about it
have you have you guys taken the oath
yet
i have not skyped yourself
yeah oh how was yay artist craig how was
it i i've not used it yet actually i uh
alex kilgore in the comments section
just reminded me i need to i need to
pull it out of my vault and
and uh commit to the oath that i took to
take the oath
i forgot about that i'm gonna try that
out uh i do not have a lot of confidence
but uh yeah we'll see we'll see
because they changed yet they changed a
lot of the the behavior of it i think
they even added some ignite their stuff
to it either or would you do something
uh sky burners then sky burners they do
something with it yeah they changed it
up um yeah they changed a lot how it
works but i haven't taken it out of the
vault
yeah i gotta go get um sunshine
oh god
oh god sunshine is stupid
bro it is stupid like i was sitting
there like oh this is broken like i was
just running through then you throw that
and put on war mine cells
man i was destroying things in the
castle
who's popping up what what nightmare
wants to come outside it's crazy your ad
control is just just crazy yeah man i
love sunshine right now sunshine is
really in a good place
yeah there's just ones like that i've
honestly forgotten about so that's a
good reminder having you sunshot yotan
has a catalyst so i know justin was
excited are you serious oh god he's got
a catalyst it's ridiculous
it's a good catalyst it's kind of broken
uh is it cornered and then also what
else does it do there's another feet
piece to it
does it increase the charge rate was
that one of the it does it alters two
stats but yeah
it doesn't give give it better tracking
or anything it just uh it makes it
totally better what it already does we
don't have to deal with irl types is
cornered which gives you a faster charge
time or drought time when surrounded by
enemies the second part is called
incandescent
and it causes scorch to spread to nearby
enemies after defeating a target that's
the fly new perk yeah oh
no that's going to be crazy but cornered
can get it does give like better charge
time if corner exactly yeah faster
charge time or draw time when surrounded
so if you're in the middle of stuff you
just want to blow up your pads
that thing up and send your little nuke
out there so i feel disgusted using that
one i can't use that one
i mean
i feel that's against my ball rules if i
can just have that catalyst faster than
anybody else in my timeline and i'm very
proud to see that i'm having fun no one
loves you
more than that man oh no that that is
that is his whole timeline his his
his body covered in made of yotans and
all that crazy stuff so sky burners i've
heard prometheus lin's got an update as
well tracer rifles
are stronger they're just 20 stronger
generally
uh
i think on
everything but red bars so they're just
they can do some more i haven't taken
the exotics out honestly i need to
prometheus i'm thinking cold heart
especially if you can just line it up on
something and just unload for a while
cold hard got done with some work as
well so there's got that one that i
haven't
played around with for sure
any uh artifact stuff you look at that
tribe that got your attention any little
mods that you like when i unlock that i
haven't i haven't dug a ton into module
just because i'm still leveling up i
think i'm looking like level 10 or
whatever but yeah
yeah i need to um
need to take a look at those
okay yeah i was like i think i just
opened that last
column but i haven't even you want to go
god damn yodan's really good though guys
thank god i believe i'm on i'm on the
last count like i've got 14 mods
unlocked but you need 14 to open the
last column right so i haven't even
experimented with those yet i need one
more to do that i got to get back to it
no doubt so wait trav what's the loadout
you're running around with what are you
running around with
i have no real dedicated loadout right
now i'm doing
i'm trying to get the uh trespasser
you know exotic done
i just i just finished um
the bow from last season that they uh oh
um
the monarch uh le mans i just i just
finished that catalyst i finished that
uh yesterday and so i'm just sort of
doing like
star chores right yeah yeah you do your
whole world
star chores uh yeah so i'm i'm just sort
of getting all that stuff done getting
my red frames and all that and trying
out things but yeah i was using uh i was
using callus mini tool for a while and
draining for a little bit so okay
i got one more question for you i saw
your tweet
so what is going on in pvp i have not
stepped foot in pvp yet
i heard there's some thoughts about
special weapon economy oh yeah yeah
what's going on break it down bro
so we talked a couple weeks ago about
how they keep changing their mind about
special ammo and as soon as pvp rolled
out the first comment i saw online was
yo
this new special ammo meadow all it does
is make it so that the people who are
good at pvp and stay alive don't have
any special ammo and the people who keep
dying spawn back with special ammo which
is exactly what
we thought it would do we talked about
this a couple weeks ago and also what
what bungie themselves has said was a
problem in the past they're like oh it
doesn't feel great to kill the other
player and then they just keep getting
special ammo um and so it it sort of
encourages like
short lives you know like you kill one
guy kill another guy and then you you
let yourself get killed because you're
getting destroyed by special ammo and
then you spawn with with special ammo
and then you're able to fight back more
aggressively um and that
sort of if you're doing sandbox design
isn't really what you wanted what you
want to do so questionable
just again so wait i forgot because i
you know that the patch noise is so damn
long so now when you kill drive
there's no green drop
basically you get like enough to kill
which is usually one bullet
there might be two for a couple random
things like a glaive maybe because i
think that takes two shots but basically
everything is one for one like you get a
shotgun kill you get one
yeah scavengers used to be like oh
because the scavenger stuff yeah you're
running out faster you basically can't
use a sniper rifle because you're never
going to be able to recover the special
ammo from the body um so it limits what
you actually use because you're probably
going to be using a shotgun or fusion
that way you can collect the special
emma right away
right and and it's it's got a weird like
kill every match is kill confirmed now
it's like if you want that special ammo
you gotta
run and recover it from the body uh
although a lot of times you'll kill them
and they drop nothing because they
didn't have any and then um
it's just like this is the exact problem
we had last time they did this
if i were making
destiny sandbox i would put special ammo
on the map you have to go and you pick
it up oh like an arena
well if you want something you have to
go and get it which then encourages you
to actually control the map and then it
rewards people who play well but it
doesn't let them just dominate they have
to continue succeeding at dom at
controlling the map if they want to keep
the resources and so that's how i would
do it um but because destiny says when
you spawn you have special ammo they're
always going to have this problem it's
either the rich get richer and just keep
stacking ammo or the poor get richer and
that it encourages these really small
lives where you just you get kills and
then when you run out of ammo you you
get killed and then god should respond
so
um yeah it's not it's not my favorite
system gotcha and last question for e2
um do you think this is going to
encourage we're going to go back to the
d1 days of like the sidearm
you know because people are like yo
screw that i ain't where i'm bus out of
sfg
remember how they went the pendulum went
the other way it was so extreme with you
know saw special ammo resources that
people would just like you know screw it
i'll just but it was like season of the
sidearm
see that everybody was using sidearms
and smg just to come back there or is it
not that serious just annoying
thoughts anyone
well like the
well i mean as you guys have basically
said it's
sniper i wonder if trials is going to be
like you know people try and pick a
couple times see if they get that first
shot it's like
that probably will still feel about the
same shotguns are probably going to be a
little more usable there i guess
some people were going to be playing
um
yeah there was there like a little
rendering hiccup bug are we good
might have been a little glitch there
sorry no big deal okay um
but it's the i
i don't know like from what i've heard
people are not a giant fan of what's
going on but also it's like this trials
you get away you get some every time
and then they change it to where after
you die you don't respawn with any more
like that gets stripped away so trials
probably is gonna feel somewhat similar
you get your couple shots if you die
cool next round all right good to go
um
but as you guys are saying it's like it
doesn't reward a good player
which is somewhat demoralizing for them
because then they're like well now i'm
just stuck with the primary it gives the
other player it gives them some chances
to you know get a couple of those shots
off per se because they the other person
may not have them but then they might
just turn and go okay well i'm going to
be more successful with the shotgun
because at least i'm close
i'm probably going to at least likely
trade or get the kill and then i can
keep going
so it's going to probably change it's
going to push snipers even farther away
as travis said
you know shotguns and snipers are
probably gonna be the more reliable kill
especially if you're the more skilled
player and the reliable ammo pickup as
well and they're just gonna probably
still hover around with the shots that
they have
no it's like it would be interesting you
know the whole special ammo box is a
little weird but it'd be an interesting
this is what crucible labs could be for
like they're just like hey we're gonna
take away scavengers and just give you
one it's like okay
what if we did you know take each map
once you guys spawn through just a
random playlist of you know
crucible and clash or whatever and just
put you know special boxes that pop up
every so often you gotta fight over them
as you said that would probably be an
interesting feeling just to compare it
just so he could be like does this work
does it not okay cool check that box but
they don't ever use the crucible labs
yeah they don't that's really sad
yeah
thank you what's the crucible
what's that
just what did that answer
is that like guided games
does that exist it's still is it guided
games or is it just yeah or raid kind of
whatever yeah i think yeah because i
remember i think i think jarv i think he
did a test where he left it running for
i think he finally found a group after
12 hours and then they beat the raid but
it took him 12 hours to find a group for
a raid using like the guided games thing
and he just was like all right here's
the test he just left it going for like
finally hours later i think he said he
found a group so wow that's crazy i
forgot it was still there sounds like an
exciting stream
riveting content there 12 hours of
queuing oh my god i'm dead
well
what else uh i mean my big question is
tomorrow can an entire dungeon save a
season that's very repetitive after like
couple days
no no dungeon is going to be able to do
that because depending on if you go for
the crafting weapons or anything else
there's only so much you can do in that
dungeon per week probably and if the you
know you do the story mission and then
the weird thing is you've got like the
so travis i wanted to see had you have
you wrapped your head around all the
currencies at this point you know how
many we got to deal with
i'm sorry if you threw up a little in
your mouth there i apologize
i i have not wrapped my head around all
of them but i am acutely aware that
there are are more than uh two
currencies so there's like the vestige
of the dread i did remove some of the uh
crafting crafting got normalized a
little bit there's still
five but there's not 12. so it's a
little better but yeah so you get the
vestiges of dread which you like deposit
in the nightmare harvester the nightmare
harvester can give you the bound
presence and then if you get the bound
presence you have to go replay the
entire story mission to cash that in
that's a weird one to me
because that's just like hey here's a
chance at something for you to go play
another activity to get the loot in
there as opposed to hey here's a chance
at another drop when you've probably
already cause you're guaranteed your
first one each week so you go through do
your three tiers get your guaranteed
first drop and then you turn around and
go to the story mission cool
but to like give you a reason to go back
into the story mission again i guess
it's not bad for a little exploration if
you miss like the robot or a bobble head
but outside of that it's outside you're
not gonna need to go experience because
i went through again i had two of them
and you can't turn more than one in at
the same time at least they did that
because it was gonna be like
play it like three times to turn all
three i was like that ain't right but
even just to go back and turn them in
again later was
odd
to say the least
enough for you um
yeah i don't know my only issue is i
just struggle with like because e let me
ask you ahead everybody um
are you able to
uh umbral focus at the the crown of
sorrow thing in the helm so
you can get four of those figments of
darkness
right yeah and i've done four of them
the next column will allow you to focus
into the opulent
and then
i think it's the fifth column is going
to be focusing the haunted weapons
going to come first and that's most of
this is like theoretically if i get up
to rank 16 this week well if i grind
that public out event out enough i could
get the one last figment that's there
and i could start focusing otherwise i
would imagine we're giving it one with
the weekly quest
and then one from a seasonal challenge
and we'll probably be doing that to
unlock them so it's mostly
there's a little like grinding you can
do but i imagine if you prestige the
crown
you're not going to be getting three
more figments in there i think it's just
like
if i get that last one at 16 that
grind's done yeah so i'm guessing it is
still fairly time gated so like you're
not even gonna be crying
yeah you're gonna be a few weeks into
the season just to start focusing the
opulent weapons that's what i wanted to
do yeah
burying currencies bungie bury me just
do it
slide me into the coffin my wet body
i just
finally figured out a t-shirt design for
you so we've got a guy in a suit covered
in all of the currencies that dusty has
here
and it's like and he's got like the the
shoes connected to a suit and there's
like a tie laying on the ground he looks
like the wizard of oz or the wicked
witch that got smashed by the house but
he's just smashed with the pile of
currencies that's travis
love it love it it's getting sacked
corpse next to the campfire that's what
you're telling me
no that's jordan
corpse
but the corpse still has a tie on he's
still dressing up
that explains why you guys are at the
campfire you went out to the woods to
bury me because i died i think there's
this whole story now we got a narrative
to the
logo the last word i've done and this is
morbid
it's a chili seasoning that got a little
dark what's up black wings you're here
for the wrap you're here for the wrap-up
of the show so just in time to catch the
ending
um okay so we know nothing about the
dungeon besides have you looked in the
collections of the weapons
i have not
they look really good
oh matter of fact i've seen them yeah
they said not so much but
on the other hand
the weapons look
fantastic the armor is like hakee's
goodwill
oh no we back on that again it's like
the daito set from prophecy when you
know it could look like the giant fire
skulls that we got and we're getting
like hakee's utility armor it's like
it's like in guardians of the galaxy
when they have i cannot remember the
name of his ship of star-lord ship and
then it's when they're in the
celestial's head and they have those
little industrial drones it's like that
they're they're functional it's
technically armor but his ship's much
flyer looking so it's like all the it's
like i've heard people worry or wonder
did they like swap it out did they put
the cool armor for the dungeon in
eververse and then give you a hockey set
in the dungeon and it's like unless
there's a reason this that set
thematically makes sense but i'm sorry
give me the fly set in the dungeon or
give me a fly set in the dungeon and a
fly set in
everest but it can't be eververse is the
coolest thing in the world and the
dungeon which you could you know and you
go work for is you know
dog water yeah that's that's the word
yeah
if you ever need a if you ever need a
negative word e
no i i've heard that's the new thing to
say that's the hip thing to say and it
gets around all the
all the worries of not saying the wrong
things so
um i'm excited to play the dungeon i
give it i give it three months till it's
considered a hate crime to say dog water
probably yeah it's not gonna be too long
but it won't be long um
i've been going back i've actually been
recently going back and watching uh
george carlin
uh some stuff of his recently because
they came out with his uh two-part
special on hbo so there's a huge special
on george carlin if you ever like
his stuff
his stuff i haven't watched it all yet
but man like i grew up loving his comedy
and some of that stuff from 25 years old
is relevant today
like if you ever want to go i will
recommend george carlin to anybody it's
like yeah he's going to have some
language in there but that is one of his
fascinations his language and enjoy it
so i was like that's what i've been like
watching a little bit tid's bits here in
the background when i've been
aimlessly grinding stuff out on the
leviathan so
but no i'm i'm hyped for the dungeon
they're usually my favorite pieces of
content so
my hope is that it will solo it day one
i'll usually i don't get a day one solo
from ibontis i'm
i'm
he's like i don't know he's like now
we're just going to kick the cheat out
of the campfire just going to see me
walking away
uh i'll probably run through it i can't
walk with black we've covered this but
anyway
what are you going to do um i'll
probably run with black wings and new
rad first just to get a feel for it just
to run through get the encounter have
multiple people with you then i'll turn
around and probably try and solo it then
work on a guide for understanding it but
yeah the first time through
are titans any good if i can't solo it i
never said titans are good if you're
gonna solo something go run a warlock
please for sure that's that's easy mode
oh we doing that again
i will no no i will just tell you like
devour is
hard to match when it comes to doing
stuff by yourself there's a reason
solo players that i've seen multiple
like content creators stuff when they go
do something first
they typically go warlock then they'll
go back and do it on the hunter or the
titan later first one they're going to
try it on almost always warlock i mean
you know it's a period class it's just
you got to go got to do what you got to
do so then own it don't like try and be
like oh you're going to throw that at me
and be like yeah we're the best start
there as opposed to having to ease into
it
own the greatness that is uh devour and
staying alive the more you kill stuff so
yeah and that went 3.00
yeah hunter's invisibility too so
yeah that's the other side of solo
did i say the triumphs for the dungeon i
have not looked that far into it yet
i'll probably explore that a little bit
but yeah um yeah first week
i'm i want to see what changes next week
that's where i'm at but i have cons i
have concerns about the
longevity of outside of tuesday's story
of what because it seems like it might
be six weeks maybe seven
roughly for the story depending on
tramps and stuff there's like six
automatons to listen to there's probably
seven for the story that you go through
for the book so seven weeks will
probably be about half the season and
then outside of that
yeah we're just gonna have to see i'm
excited for the dungeon those are always
very fun
i have spent a lot of time i've spent a
lot of time in the last couple days
playing this but
again even for a casual player they're
probably going to see
some of the repetitions sooner than they
might in say psyops battlegrounds and
then go doing i feel like
slaps were they were just longer to go
through
yeah and then we knew we had three of
those if this doesn't get a rotation
it's gonna it's gonna be one of those
things when you because we've had a lot
of like boss will be different
if you're standing in the same place
though that's gonna be it's gonna be
kind of sad
all i got to add is
my focus is the iron lord title baby
that's next week so that's next week
playing right i expect you to have that
title i would have going down before the
podcast
bro actually most i'll buy i might i'm
not going to i might whatever i think
all the harder stuff i got all the
seasonal i got like three or four steps
already done proactively
they gave it i was like oh i'm ready and
then the rest is just like play it's
just like continue to oh it's going down
man i saw those two oh i can't wait to
have that over my name
can't wait that's that's that's my goal
i got my little um you know fragment
stuff i want to do but yeah with you i
just got to see i got to see what they
do long term because if not then it will
be
season of the finishing of the games
you know but i like it i'm having fun we
just want to see where they go but the
story is what's keeping me right now
trav
um
yeah i'm like i said i'm not loving it
but uh i'm going to uh
i'm going to keep playing i'm going to
try i'm excited to try the dungeon i'm
excited to try rift did get a new
crucible map uh which i don't think i've
gotten that to show up in queue yet
actually i definitely haven't um so i
guess i need to get around to doing that
um and yeah and cog you know
don't worry
you got easy mode on
your warlock character but
he got easy mode in real life so you
know
balances itself out he's messy today
he's all over the place he's super messy
today
yeah yeah that's that's fitting i don't
usually say messy but
travis i think fits that one today yeah
okay here we go we got iron banner
coming we got that rift
yeah we got rift coming and then as
blackwing was saying it's like the story
story is kind of what i'm here for at
this point i'm here for the story
uh there's the one line i don't know if
you guys heard the one where eris tells
you about her ghost
yes
man that one hit
that hit like i saw it on twitter and
then i listened to it and i was like
damn
yeah she's been a comforting thing she's
been a confident name she also said
she's a new witch
yes yeah so i have i have wonders about
that as well so
again i'm here for the story it's just
like if we do a public event for 13
weeks that's gonna kind of hurt
yeah and then will it will they do what
they did with season of risen where they
kind of cut the story in the middle and
just let us rock and then it's over you
know i'm very curious to see how they
like six seven weeks so i mean you're
still gonna have
you know however many left of you're
gonna have at least half the season of i
mean there's not a raid there's not
difficulties coming for the raid so i
mean those things aren't coming in this
season
so
yeah i would imagine you're going to
have some backlog time
yeah it feels like it
love it see how it goes
love it
well that's about all i got i just got
the really bad news that my advanced gg
order got damaged for the second time
your powder yeah
wow
you got ripped off by a rival um cartel
they stole your powder
yeah
somebody at you
one of your trucks yeah one of the
delivery drivers must be like a
different partner and they're like no
i'm taking away the sales or something
let's just
game us up say i gotta stop man it's
wall we're going to walk going away yeah
they keep in your truck
man i have been waiting for this order
like i got it's the one it was delivered
fifths of it was
not in the package last time i got a
package delivered that was open
oh no they out here sniffing the powder
before you get the price yeah
i can't wait for the scene where the
advanced gg headquarters it's a bunch of
people working in their underwear
okay
shout out to the ceo
shout out to the ceo his name's peter
he's on advance he's on twitter but
shout out to him if somebody like
photoshops a picture of him
in front of the big pile of powder like
in scarface it's over
yeah that's stupid but no i was getting
more hydration and then a new flavor as
well and i've been trying to try oh i'm
so annoyed so yeah it got like damaged
and it was being returned to center i'm
pissed
but i was like because it was supposed
to be delivered today and i was like why
does it not happen why does it not
happen then i finally was like i checked
and really yeah so anyway uh there is a
buy one get one sale going on literally
buy one jar get one completely 100 off
which is probably one of the bigger
sales that they ever do so if you guys
don't want to use that use code iron
lord use cody bontis um it's for the
long weekend that we've got going on so
um but that's about all i got i think
tomorrow's gonna be
who's going to either make or break some
of the grade for the season though yeah
we'll see how it goes today if they they
need a strong one otherwise
this seasonal ranking will go down for
sure we'll see how it goes but yeah for
me
samos actually [ __ ] it at the beach
what are you what you got going what's
going on with you why don't you go first
man okay yeah i don't gotta go all right
cool doesn't be friendly um no for me
just like uh you know obviously
duke is outside so shout out to maddie
got another episode out there talking
about all the madness of twitter and so
cancel game pass is that the one i just
talked
publicly announcing things and you know
so we get it to all that you know yeah
it's just it was a fun spicy show shout
out to him
um we did a i did an um ultimate with
addict so that was fun we broke down the
halo tv series episode by episode travis
boy oh boy
that sounds like a how much of a
devastating time an exercise in
nihilistic tendencies
i care for attic made it so entertaining
like it was it was it was fun listen to
him go off on certain things so that was
cool and then um yesterday will be the
lord's day i think i think we got a
recording coming through so it should be
good check this out on sunday that
should be fun and then the countdown to
my brothers very soon
getting we we're approaching
gcx soon i got to take care of my
recovery business which i found out the
thanks to e
i'll bring one for you man yeah i was
like i got plenty as well so we're good
yeah so we just in case my boys got me
on the back up but i'm looking forward
to it and um yeah that's pretty much all
that's going on with me what about you
trav what's going on any new reviews any
new things yeah i got lots of content um
my review i think i already talked about
my review of evil dead that was a while
ago that's the that's the latest review
i've gotten um we're waiting for june
games to start coming out before i do
more reviews um
i'd done a bunch of previews i did a
preview of roller champions which is a
free-to-play roller derby sports game
where you're rolling around and dunking
a ball through a hoop and it's super
stupid and fun it's free
so you can play that
um and then i've got a couple previews i
can't talk about and some other content
i'm working on i also made a 13 tips
video that should be live tomorrow so if
you are playing evil dead the game and
you want uh pro tips from a guy who's
played way too much of that game highly
recommend watching that video nice um
and i think i'm going to start doing
zero weekly videos um
i don't know why this is earthing just
apparently people love clicking on zur
stuff because every week they're like
getting enough traffic from the articles
yeah they're like travis you need to
make more more observer the internet the
algorithm you love zur for some reason
so yeah seo is big enough you're
probably killing it yeah apparently
weird
other than that i'm really excited i'm
just stealing all my views so just
thinking
about every every video you want to talk
about
my back yeah
right now that's why i've gotta give you
shout outs now because i'm gonna be
doing i'm gonna be doing steal my job
yeah it's fine when my channel collapses
i'll just deploy territory come on my
channel man we'll do co let's plays oh
there you go
anyway uh 1v1 and pvp and then you can
just school me
travis teaches ibontes how to play pvp
uh i'd love to man i'd love to uh yeah
other than that i'm really excited for
gcx um you can watch uh episodes of
bitcast every sunday where i argue with
the lawyer
um and uh talk to a man who's rapidly
decaying into the forum which we will
all soon meet um
death and uh
yeah
buy some powder from these guys uh use
the code narcos
[Laughter]
just for all of the law enforcement out
there we're talking about advanced gg
just to be
i'm clear have a knock on my door after
the episode and be like sir we need to
talk
my long con to swat uh yeah when i've
been when i'm getting served of a
warrant in here be like we've got a
search warrant
i feel like all the powders in here you
can test everything you want to know
hilarious you want to know a hilarious
thing actually so i told you guys last
week i was going to go visit my brother
in austin and i did
and i took some focus down there in my
backpack
so i don't know it's like i forgot one
of those like little like individual
peanut butter things that you could take
so that may have been like what caused
the x-ray and then they searched it and
like what are these i took like four
jars because i wanted my brother to try
a couple took the powder out of the
focus jaw and put it into another job
well they were in these they were in the
joke but i had four of them in there and
he opened them up smelled them all but
they had they did like a little swab on
the side and they put in the machine is
like we've got an alarm i'm like
i literally had to do like
that's advantage
they had to do the whole literal neck
down back of their hands over the crotch
pad like did they stop they pull you off
the line and put you in a little 100 not
in the room but i'm just sitting there
like the guy's like going you know arms
and everything okay i'm gonna use back
of my hands literally just straight back
and forth across my crotch i was like
what is happening right now and then
after he gets through security it cuts
to a scene of ibontis in the bathroom
and he's reopening the jar and he
reaches into the powder and pulls out a
smaller baggie
[Laughter]
he's like they never
works every time and that's the end of
the episode
thank you guys for being here yeah so
that was a fun little adventure but um
yeah very excited for gcx if you guys
are coming find us i'll be wearing my
shirt i never got a shirt made because
the one time i went down that path it's
just
absolute train wreck there may be a
weird shirt design that gets posted at
some point for me if you guys ever want
to buy a weird looking cheetah t-shirt
it's probably gonna happen
well okay there's one that i'm actually
kind of okay posting because it was like
a cool cheetah the second one that
happened was a trash fire and i will i
will never sell that one but one of them
was okay the other one that happened
after i'd like hey can you tweak a
couple of things and the artist like
redid the entire thing and made it worse
i was like oh okay so we're done
um
but yeah you guys fall of the cheating
yo this chat is hilarious yeah chatbot
fire tonight tips guides videos and
cartel kingfish
so listen this is definitely the last
episode
yeah
this has been
the last episode
this has been yeah this has been the
last episode of the last last word
yeah we did we just couldn't make it to
200.
everything fell apart right there at one
night
episode 200 is a live stream from the
courthouse
the actual last word is the verdict
last word is guilty
all right thank you guys chad's been on
fire all of you guys out there wherever
you watch this on youtube on iron lord
cognitive channel on ibonta's channel if
you listen to us in your ears take us
with you on itunes spotify google play
all the other podcast platforms leave us
a good review drop a like on the video
share it with your friends if they like
destiny and let them know it gets a
little crazy in the end uh thank you
guys very much for getting us all the
way to 199. i've got some plans for 200
not sure if that's happening now or
maybe a little bit later but we'll do a
cool episode coming up soon when things
come together but all of you guys have
been amazing chad has been awesome my
co-host i couldn't do this without you
guys so shout out to coming up on 200
all of you are amazing and for this
episode it has been
the last word